hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are joined
by Ted T here from d-neck animation you
are the global head of animation and
we're going to be looking at a whole
bunch of stuff that you've done over the
last how many years a long time a long
time years
31. wow you've survived the transition
from traditional to 3D and you had to
make the jump yourself yeah so I worked
at Disney and traditional animation
doing hand drawn and then I switched
over to do CG animation at DreamWorks
the man has worked from Lion King to
Lilo and Stitch all the way to nimona
and a couple other modern pieces I've
been very lucky and fortunate to have
like a really fun career where I've
learned a lot and I've worked with a lot
of great people and who are generous
with me and taught me a lot too well
you've worked on a lot of amazing pieces
and Ted has a lot of Amazing Stories so
let's jump into it
[Music]
wow look at that ghost Mufasa a
brilliant animator named Tony fuccelli
animated Mufasa and Reuben Kino animated
adult Simba and the lip sync that is on
Mufasa Tony kind of pioneered it it was
just the timing and if any animation
nerd wants to like still frame when he's
saying like Simba
[Music]
it was just the pace of how he dropped
the jaw hit the bottom and came back up
you know off of a consonant into a vowel
and the way it was so fluid and fleshy
and it hadn't really been done believe
it or not and everyone started trying to
do the same pattern on all their
animation the director's like just just
animate normally
yeah you know 2D back in the day was a
mixture of like ancient secrets that
people thought that they had you know
and and now in the CG era everyone's
very sharing but back then you kind of
had to figure it out on your own as you
went along no one sat down and a lot of
people think that it wasn't technical
but it was actually 2D was very very
technical in terms of how you could
approach it to be efficient and to be
quick as well but there's a lot of lost
Secrets at this level of Animation that
there's no one really to pass things
along dang yeah the challenge of 2D
animation was also the joy in it and the
fact that you have like a blank piece of
paper and you really had to learn to
draw like that was your language you
know like now people who Adept with Maya
and with CG specific tools are able to
communicate better and back then it was
a question of your draftsmanship and if
you drew well it just helped you more
but now I find the beauty in CG is that
when you're really willing to share with
others and support them everyone gets
better you learn more performances are
improving and and now that you know know
you've got films like you know
spider-verse and TMNT like but I like
that people are really trying new things
and going back to Old timing like
everyone's like oh spidey's on twos and
fours well this was too way back in the
day and I'm glad we're bringing that in
all right we're gonna take a break from
the circle of life to talk about the
square of life that's right
squarespace.com the sponsor of today's
video now if you are in the market for a
website well you've probably heard it
before at squarespace.com it's a great
place to start they have this cool thing
called the fluid engine where you can
build a template one of their
award-winning templates and you can mix
and match things drag them around it's
really intuitive and easy plus if you're
running merch you can fulfill orders and
run all that through automated
Squarespace store you can do point of
sale stuff you can run online stores you
can have member areas you know there's a
whole bunch of options when it comes to
Squarespace website layouts now if you
didn't know it already corridor's first
website was actually made for the square
aspect ratio we looked at on Square
monitors so you know we go real far back
with that that shape so if you are
looking to build a website well you can
start a free trial on squarespace.com
and if you want 10 off a website
purchase or domain purchase well
squarespace.com Corridor crew will get
you that all your website folks check it
out all the people that don't need a
website don't worry about it back to the
video the names
your Sidekick has arrived I don't need a
sign every villain needs a sidekick yeah
so nimona is a very fascinating movie
and can you tell us a little bit about
like where this movie came from how it
came to be yeah I mean I think it's kind
of legendary now how they had started it
at Blue Sky and then unfortunately you
know uh Disney ended up closing the
studio and ended up coming to us at
d-neck very thankfully and they didn't
really get a big jump on it you know in
animation they had a couple of sequences
done and unfortunately it's just
beautiful work but we couldn't use it
because of the technicalities so we just
started over
where did the
instead of CG 3D movie yeah but it looks
2D in its art style yeah like how do you
make that work
yeah well obviously you know on the art
director Aiden sugano had a huge
influence and uh Archie Donato who was
head of lighting one of the VFX soups
you know they wanted to maintain it by
not going to like the typical realistic
kind of sense of occlusion you know it's
cool because you still have a lot of
Bloom and reflectivity in the armor for
instance and it's kind of very shiny but
it's also has a flat look like you said
because of like handling the ambient
occlusion in kind of a non-realistic way
to keep it very graphic and it just
helps everything integrate the
backgrounds integrate the characters
integrate they don't pop off and yet
their Silhouettes are very clear
everything's about Clarity storytelling
and emotional Clarity there
yeah it's really great you know the fun
part about it is that we're not supposed
to know what to think of her we wanted
her to be like inspired by the
explosiveness of Beetlejuice and kind of
like Bugs Bunny at the same time who's
always under control but not and so that
was really her thing she's unpredictable
in her because you don't know what she
stands for you don't know what she's
about she stands for chaos well and she
actually does and she's not pretending
to be chaotic she really is that way oh
look it's glory
the only feeling that Bugs Bunny vibe
from her yeah also too a lot of
animators personalities came out Pat
puhala did these and he's just wanted to
put that punk side of her in really
clearly one interesting thing in this
movie is that like you'll see here we
use itrace very heavily I trace can you
elaborate on that for sure so if you
look at a lot of the shots the main
character that you're watching at the
end of one shot will be roughly in the
same place in the next shot where a
character is staged okay so your eye
doesn't need to jump around and your
eyes can follow easily where you need
and here you can see that Bell is quite
still and you have nimona moving a lot
and then she looks over at him and he
starts to talk a bit
and she was in the same place at the end
of that last shot as the beginning of
the next one it's kind of like when they
shot Fury Road how they framed a lot of
the actions exactly you never have to
actually search for the option yep and
also too there's a lot more profile in
our film like this is three-quarter but
there's a lot of profile in our film
because one I think the character
designs are really really strong but
secondly the directors weren't afraid to
have them face each other and big fat
you unicorn fat unicorn yeah you saw it
I like how it pushes his hair yeah yeah
exactly the thing that about profile
that works great is that the contact is
so direct you have two characters
three-quarter you're kind of cheating it
right because yeah technically if I was
three quarter in your three-quarter it's
like we're not really looking at each
other unless you're looking at you know
but profile works so well and normally
in future animation it's a taboo thing
you're like turn them three-quarter turn
them three-quarter oh interesting yeah
why why is that the case uh it's the
case because usually in three quarter
the designs look much more appealing you
see the far eye the design is a lot
clearer but because we wanted to keep it
very graphic you know Nate Stevens sends
a graphic novel it's a webcomic and it's
very very stylized so it helped our
characters stay very very graphic and
clear
so like nimona she's a shape-shifter
she's able to transform into all these
different creatures like from a
character animation standpoint is that
just like a field day like all right now
she's gonna be a hippo now she's gonna
be a dragon or a shark that walks and
then so it becomes about making the
behaviors consistent across all forms
you know using the eyes and eyebrows as
a link to them but also using like head
spacing to make all the characters feel
the same but what's really fun is also
putting animal traits of that like of a
wolf or a bear or a horse into that to
make it also feel animal-like but in
terms of like the literal
Transformations they're very simple
now a lot of it's like sleight of hand
so
um a lot of our rigors our rigging team
just like came through big time is that
hilarious and really it's just shapes
transforming into one another we use a
lot of squash and stretch to hide
transitions they're really really quick
within a couple of frames and then
really the the things to spend as little
time in the middle as possible and to
finish in a nice slow-in in the final
form that she transforms into also
effects could follow up with either that
sparkly effect or Ribbon effect yeah to
make it really easy to track I love this
film everyone who worked on this film so
emotional about it like even for me just
a lot of hard work went in and anyone
who's ever been associated with the film
The Blue Sky crew our crew d-neg
animation we just put every
ounce of effort and Care into sharing
the message and trying to make it as
beautiful as we could yeah I'm gonna
watch this movie with my cool like it
has to happen oh by the way I'm just
gonna throw it out there just saying if
you enjoy this content hit that
subscribe button you won't miss out on
future ones and it helps us we all win
all right saying
hello are there any aminals in here
how dude I Remember Loving Lilo and
Stitch that was such a good movie were
you like five I was I I was older than
five
he watched it for the first time last
year
30.
read the read the charges
Captain gantu was my character and it
was the first time that I was assigned
my own character on a Disney movie which
was really exciting and a real point of
Pride for me and this was a great shot
because he's you know 25 30 feet tall he
wouldn't move around a lot like a normal
human so you'd have to find a pose that
reads he's like part Shark part elephant
yeah that's exactly right he was meant
to be elephant killer whale a ram and
Iron Man an Iron Man yeah yeah now
notice that there's some use of 3D
models here like those guns are sales
it's digital models yeah I remember
reading that the use of 3D models was
oftentimes inspired by having to draw a
rigid shape yeah orbiting in 3D space
yeah we often ask each other like why
does it need to be animated in this case
clearly anything that's mechanical as
those guns were is a clear choice to do
in CG you have to remember when this was
made that was a big deal to do those
guns right right our CG Department was
dying to to do something like that yeah
exactly because this film really stood
for a great combination of CG as well as
traditional techniques like watercolor
all these backgrounds are watercolors I
was about to say it's like everything is
just like a watercolor everyone is a
literal watercolor painting that's
incredible
um
this whole sequence here you want to
know a story here yeah
Yeah so basically we've done a sequence
where Stitch hijacks a 747 instead of
this red spaceship and he flies through
Honolulu and he flies along the side of
a building and all the glass breaks it
was done and then 911 happened oh
yeah we had to do it over but
miraculously we turn that sequence
around and ended up on budget we
actually were below Budget on this film
huh dude when's the last time you heard
that it's like like a mystical thing to
hear yeah I love this film again it's
very easy to look at and again just
Mastery and Direction you know I I think
directors sometimes weirdly get
forgotten in like the craft of it but
Chris and Dean are great and equally
Nick and Troy were fantastic as well
also I don't know who did that chocolate
chip mint ice cream but I felt like I
could taste it yeah it's like I was like
I know exactly what that cartoon tastes
like
[Music]
so obviously you're now doing all of
this 3D animation but you got your start
in 2D animation at some point you had to
transition over into using computers
yeah like what was that like what
project was it it was Shark Tale Shark
Tale Shark Tales Will Smith let's let's
take a look big old envelope full of
money
give it to Mr Sykes come on hurry up
hurry up the human teeth is an
interesting touch on a thing interesting
is a great word I don't like that other
movie he did Sonic uh
meow yeah I loved working on Sonic
well I guess that makes me Oscar the
millionaire the millionaire I did that
shot that was like my second shot the
Angelina Jolie fish
[Laughter]
I see that the bottom like all the
joints of the hair on the bottom are
like oh my God I just I just made like I
just made the wave work as well as
possible the curve type they used on
this film was Beast blind and it has a
lot of natural overshoots right that you
use a Euler filter to flatten out
normally but I didn't know the
difference but because they're
underwater that overshoot worked super
well because it made him look like he
floated and came back down through no
skill of my own and then so I'm like
this is great but I remember thinking to
myself if I had to do a walk if they
weren't underwater I might not have
continued at DreamWorks they probably
would have let me go because I couldn't
do a walk so do you think there's a
decision to make it a fish movie because
you didn't have to deal with that kind
of stuff no but I'm really thankful that
it was
when you focus on Kung Fu you suck we
actually haven't talked about Kung Fu
Panda yet on the show no surprisingly
right yeah it was our first time tell me
about what you worked on uh Kung Fu
Panda was very interesting because first
of all any film about martial arts uh
growing up big martial artist and I did
it for a long time and a big fan of
anything martial arts
I have come home must I really had fun
with these shots uh Ian mcshane's voice
here he's kind of taunting shufu this
was my probably the most fun shot
because uh the voice performance was so
good he's being sarcastic and he laughs
there they just felt like very truthful
performances that's always where I felt
like I can jump in to the skin of the
character a little bit better
so these were some other great animator
shots and then in this sequence here
this was Jay Rice eggs really cool shot
here with the reflection yeah do you
animate the speed ramps as in like yeah
I made them slow you don't just slow
down later yeah all the speed ramps were
just done by hand and this sequence too
when he grabs the staff this was great
because I got to do this section and
where he starts to choke Shifu here and
the staff starts to tremble yeah
until it snaps and you know all that is
really it's because it just happened to
be that that staff was rigged perfectly
like because when it's bending it's
going to bend in a different place once
pressure is applied it bent in the right
places and it had a pivot that I could
slide up and down the staff and so just
because of that it was really the staff
that made that shot look good because it
worked perfectly and I just trembled it
it's like used a lot of like old 2D
tricks in terms of staggers and stuff
and everyone's like what are you doing
what's a stagger and a stagger is just a
series of frames that are the same frame
but you just do them out of order but
it's the same frame so you have like one
three two two three one and you just
keep changing it up and it makes sense
yeah so it looks like a tremble but it's
really a lot easier than it looks and
then later on there's a part where he's
chasing pull up a building and pull
kicks these roof tiles into Tai Long's
face and I remember just really doing a
stagger
here back here back and I remember there
was an animator who was much more
experienced at CG than myself and he's
like what are you doing and I go oh I'm
just doing a stagger on the head because
once there's effects and those tiles are
hitting him in the face I want it to
feel really abrupt and and sharp like if
a tile hit you in the face
and if you make it too refined and too
fancy you'll miss the the kind of
brutality of like just like Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam being hit repeatedly how to
respond uh he didn't believe me
and then so finally when it finally was
done in lighting and comp I think it
ended up working you know and he came
back and he says I didn't think it would
work but it looks cool so I was glad you
told so many different stories we talked
about so many different movies we can't
possibly fit all of this on YouTube so
there's an extended version of this
episode on our website
quarterdigital.com right now you can
check it out with the free trial thank
you so much for watching this was a
really fun one to do Ted thank you so
much for joining us that was a lot of
fun I love hearing all your crazy
stories about going through all the
different animation films and your
transition from 2D to 3D that was
special so thanks for sharing thanks
it's super fun thanks for having me like
I get to see the studio and talk about
animation amazing things yeah it was
really fun thanks for having me here
absolutely one thing for you to do you
got
it's on Netflix I
[Applause]
fix right right now
yeah you're also sharing passwords right
awesome it's fine
uh